اهلا بكم من جديد جنوب افريقيا تتعاقد على
شراء خمس مسيرات كبيره الحجم محليه الصنع
لاول مره
المسيره التي تنتجها شركه ميلكور الجنوب
افريقيا هي مسيره تكتيكيه تسمى ميلكور 380
بحسب الشركه فستكون هذه المسيره منافسا
قويا لنظيراتها من المسيرات التي حتى
تقدمها شركات كبرى حول العالم للمزيد حول
هذه المسيره وكذلك المنظومات الاخرى التي
تنتجها شركه ميلكور الجنوب افريقيا ينضم
الينا السيده مارتينيوس الرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه بالسعوديه اولا مصر اهلا بك معنا
في عسكري تاريا يعني ما الذي يميز مسيره
ميلكور 380 جعلكم تقولون بانها تستطيع
منافسه كبرى المسيرات نظيراتهم النظيراتها
في العالم
لقد استثمرت شركتنا كثيرا من اجل تنويع
الخبرات الموجوده في فريق التطوير في
الشركه اذ يتوفر لدينا طيف واسع من
الخبراء الذين يعملون في مجالات واسعه لا
سيما في حق التصميم والتطوير وكذلك في
مجال الالكترونيات والاتصالات المتخصصه
وقد سمح ذلك للشركه بزياده توفير انظمه
لمنتجاتنا داخل مصانعنا وهو عامل من شانه
بطبيعه الحال ان يحد من مخاطر الامداد
عندما يتعلق الامر بمتطلبات الصيانه
واصلاح الانظمه وتحديثها
كما اننا حريصون على ان تكون منتجاتنا
متطابقه مع المعايير والجوده العالميه وهو
ما ييسر عمليه الاستخدام
والمتطلبات اللوجستيه الخاصه لدى الجهات
المستخدمه لهذه الانظمه على وجه التحديد
لكن فيما يتعلق بمسيره ميلكو 380 مصر
مرتينوس انتم لديكم تعاقد مع جيش جنوب
افريقيا اين وصلتم في هذا التعاقد وكذلك
هل هناك دول مهتمه بهذه المسيره اخرى وما
هي هذه الدول
لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق مع سلاح الجو في
جنوب افريقيا الذي يقوم بموجب الاتفاق
بتجربه وتقييم الطائره المسيره وفقا
لمتطلباته بغيت تزويدنا بملاحظاته حولها
ويتضمن الاتفاق ايضا بعد حالات الاستخدام
العملياتي وصولا الى نشر هذه الطائره
المسيره بشكل كامل ويعود السبب في ذلك الى
اننا نفضل العمل مع مستخدمي منتجاتنا
لنفهم احتياجاتهم على الرغم من توفر فريق
فني مقتدر لدى الشركه بالنسبه للنشاطنا
على الصعيد العالمي لدينا وجود كبير في
اكثر من 70 بلدا يتم تسويق منتجاتنا فيها
بفضل كفاءه قسم التسويق في الشركه ولقد
اجرينا قدرا كبيرا من النقاشات رفيعه
المستوى لاسيما بشان الطائره الم
ونحن متفائلون جدا حيال المبيعات
المستقبليه لهذه المسيره
مستر مارتينوس فيما يتعلق بقيود التصدير
هل هناك اي قيود تصدير معينه تفرضها عليكم
الحكومه في جنوب افريقيا سواء فيما يتعلق
بمسيره ميلكون 380 او حتى غيرها من
المنتجات التي تقدمونها في الشركه سواء
لدول في منطقه الشرق الاوسط او حتى لبقيه
الدول على مستوى العالم
الجواب هو كلا لان منطقه الشرق الاوسط
كانت تاريخيا زبولا مهما لصناعه الدفاع في
جنوب افريقيا ولم نواجه على مدى السنين
قيودا او عراقيل كبرى بشان هذا النوع من
الصادرات كما تربط حكومات بلداننا علاقات
جيده والدليل على ذلك عدد مشاركات حكومه
جنوب افريقيا في القمم التي عقدت بين
الجانبين
من جهه شركتنا نحن نبذل ايضا جهودا في
مجال توطين صناعه الدفاع في البلد الذي
ننشط فيه الامر الذي يجعل المتطلبات
اللوجستيه والصادرات اكثر كفاءه
لديكم الان ثلاث مكاتب في ثلاث دول
السعوديه وكذلك الامارات وايضا في الهند
كيف عزز وجود مثل هذه المكاتب من مكانتكم
الدوليه كشركه عامله في الصناعات الدفاعيه
وكذلك هل لديكم خطه للتوسع اكثر في
المستقبل ام لا
لقد كان لمكاتبنا الدوليه بشكل عام تاثير
ايجابي على الشركه لاننا نرى انفسنا شركه
عالميه تقدم حلول الدفاع وقد سمح لنا فتح
هذه المكاتب بالعمل مباشره مع مستخدمي
منتجاتنا في كل بلد علاوه على الاستفاده
من العلاقات التي تربط البلد الذي نوجد
فيه بالبلدان المجاوره والحلف
السوق بالنسبه لنا واسعه وتسمح لنا باخذ
البلدان التي لديها الرغبه في التعاون مع
شركات عالميه مثل شركتنا في الحسبان
واستطيع ان اعطيك مثالا جيدا على ذلك
فاختيارنا للوجود في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه يعود للتعاون والدعم الذي وفرته
الحكومه السعوديه
للجهات الفاعله العالميه من اجل الاستثمار
في السوق المحليه
والمساعده في تنميه قدرات السعوديه في
مجال الدفاع وهذا التوجه يتماشى تماما مع
سياسه ورؤيه شركتنا السعيه الى التوسع
مثل مارتينوس الصناعات الدفاعيه في
افريقيا بشكل عام بدات تظهر مؤخرا لكن كيف
نقيم الصناعات الدفاعيه في افريقيا بشكل
عام من وجهه نظرك كاحد الموجودين في احدى
هذه الشركات الرائده الان في جنوب افريقيا
ان القاره الافريقيه قاره ناميه الى حد
كبير ولديها الكثير من الامكانات التي لم
تسخر في السابق والصناعه في افريقيا تغيرت
بشكل عام انا شخصيا اكثر ارتباطا بمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط لكننا قمنا بدور كبير في
تطوير منتجات في اسواق افريقيا المحليه
بالاعتماد على المهارات المحليه
مثل مارتينوس الحرب في اوكرانيا انعكست
بشكل كبير على الشركات العامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه وكان لها اثر سواء في
الخطط الانتاج المتعلقه بالوقت الحالي او
حتى في المستقبل كيف يعني اثرت هذه الحرب
على خططكم سواء الحاليه او المستقبليه في
مساله الانتاج
بالنسبه لتاثير الحرب علينا كشركه مصنعه
نحن على علم ببعض الملاحظات التي صدرت حول
هذا الصراع ويمكن ان اشير في الصدد الى
مساله الموثوقيه والدعم الخاصه بالمنتجات
خلال تنفيذ العمليات وهو ما دفعنا الى
اعداد بعض التصميمات من اجل تعظيم هذه
القدرات الى جانب تطبيق تكنولوجيات جديده
من اجل معالجه اوجه القصور التي ظهرت خلال
تنفيذ العمليات
مصر مارتينيوس دوبيرا رئيس التنفيذي لشركه
ميلكور الجنوب افريقيا بالسعوديه شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا